for Ukraine's children some too young to
understand the war the snow provides a
welcome distraction from the conflict
for older youths it's a
struggle Constantine kic has been trying
to cope with the trauma of being forced
from his hometown of aiva now completely
destroyed I'm very sorry to lose the
house in which I grew up and for my
school which is gone and for my friends
who are no longer around and that
feeling of ship which is not there
anymore helped in his recovery by one of
Ukraine's largest youth support
organizations he now helps run group
activities for other young people
affected by War we can show uh today's
teenager that there are still reasons to
move forward and to make themsel happy
and to make their choices because of
course some of them are really suffering
youth support groups are also warning
about the long-term harm of anxiety and
Trauma being endured by the young posing
problems they say well into adulthood if
left untreated now Lisa demchenko is one
of a team of trained psychology students
providing online
counseling they need our support right
now and if we delay it maybe be too late
because they can develop various
disorders like anxiety and
depression a recent study by this group
showed half of the teenagers surveyed
currently feel some degree of anxiety
and with the war grinding on with no end
in sight only 18% said they felt free of
stress and truly happy about their
future Rob McBride Al jazer
Kei make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer